GREY: This weekend,
the American public
saw some upsetting things
about the current state
of U.S. immigration.
The Trump administration policy
of zero tolerance
that has resulted
in nearly 2,000 children
being separated
from their families.
GREY: I was so upset
I had to do something about it,
which is why...
I'm here in D.C. to expose
the Democrats' cruel treatment
of Trump's immigration policies.
They want to open up our borders
like Swiss cheese
and let MS-13 run for Congress.
Conservatives agree
immigrant families are scary.
Alien minors.
They look so innocent.
They're not innocent.
You have unaccompanied minors
coming over
with gang affiliation.
-Don't come to this country
-Tomi, let me...
-and complain about the rule
of law. -Tomi, let me ask you...
These child actors
weeping and crying
on all the other networks
24/7 right now.
Do not fall for it,
Mr. President.
GREY: Over the weekend,
eight Dems had the gall
to question this policy
by visiting
these detention centers
to-- get this--
see if the kids were okay.
Their sick ringleader,
Senator Jeff Merkley of Oregon,
who wants us to believe
this attitude
towards immigrants is inhumane.
I think
that is a horrific attitude
for the United States.
Instead of protecting children,
we're going to proceed
to inflict harm on them.
GREY: The first time he visited,
they called the cops on him,
which makes sense,
because the conservative media
knows that Merkley
is the real threat here.
Is this just a publicity stunt?
Oh, it's completely a stunt.
I mean, he had the media there.
GREY:
Well, guess what, libs?
I can play at this
publicity stunt game, too.
I'm gonna turn the tables.
I'm here at his office.
Watch him throw me out.
-Oh, hi, Laura
from The Opposition. -Oh.
-I'm so glad you found
my office. -Hi.
He's probably calling the cops
on me right now.
-Come on in.
-Okay.
So, we're just gonna talk?
Let's jump in.
So, tell me a little bit
about your decision
to visit the processing center,
this publicity stunt of yours.
So, my agenda was to find out
if we had, in fact,
implemented this new policy
of traumatizing children
by tearing them away
from their families
when the refugees
are coming to seek asylum.
How far are you willing to go
with these publicity stunts?
What's next?
Are you gonna shed light
on sexual accusations
against ICE?
Are you gonna shed light
on the fact
that statistically
there is no correlation
between immigrant populations
and violent crime?
Where does it end?
Well, I would say
we need a lot of light shined
on a catastrophic policy
that's being financed
with our taxpayer dollars.
-So you admit it?
-Absolutely.
Boom. Caught that on camera.
You're fighting for this
humanitarian children's cause.
Guilty.
GREY:
Busted!
Before, when families
were detained at the border,
they were typically
kept together
to await civil trial.
Now, under Trump,
all migrants
crossing the border
are criminally prosecuted,
which means
the parents go to jail
while their kids
are given a blanket
and shipped off
to a detention center
to hang out in a cage.
Some have referred to them
as "cages,"
but keep in mind,
they built walls
out of chain-link fences.
GREY:
Sorry, not cages.
I meant a wall made out
of a chain-link fence.
Totally different.
The point is
it's not really that bad.
It was a shocking sight
to walk in initially,
just to see so many people
so distressed,
a number of people crying.
They look like big cages
or maybe the way you would
construct a dog kennel.
Do you know kids?
You throw a cage
in the middle of the room,
and they'll run into it.
It's, like, basically
a free jungle gym.
Well, it didn't appear
that any children
were having much fun
when I was there.
GREY: Merkley seems determined
to inhumanely force Trump
to separate from his campaign
promises on immigration.
I would love to be able
to rip that policy from them
and-and end it.
You're a monster.
Merkley's ridiculous stunt
of showing the plight
of children
in cages on American soil
is somehow working.
Democrats, former first ladies,
current first ladies,
Republicans like Rick Scott
are even crossing
sacred party lines
to speak out against it.
And I don't think there's
any moral code in the universe
or any religious tradition
that finds it morally acceptable
to hurt children
in order to influence parents.
These asylum seekers
are individuals
who have gone through
horrific circumstances.
That's seared into my mind.
That's going to stick with me
for a long time.
Lucky for me,
nothing gets seared in here.
Dead as a doornail inside.
There is one other
American hero
who is also dead inside,
and here is what he's saying
about the immigration policy.
With all of that being said,
we're doing a great job.
(air horn blowing)